- I feel like we should
win something, you guys.
- You better have a prize.
Because I'm gonna be pissed off.
- Yeah, I feel like we need to go shopping
at Van Cleef after this.
(lighthearted music)
Hi, I'm Sean Hayes.
- And I'm Debra Messing.
And we are playing the Buzzfeed BFF test.
(lighthearted music)
- I'm not looking.
I got my answer.
(lighthearted music)
Getting lipstick, I
was gonna say lipstick!
I swear to God I was gonna say lipstick.
- That was my other thing.
(laughs)
(lighthearted music)
- (laughs) Okay, ready?
Yes, I didn't want to say that!
But that's what I wrote!
- (laughs) Imitate Gracie's mom.
(gasps) We are best friends!
Oh, my God!
This is so great (laughs).
When he imitated Debbie Reynolds
in the scene and I farted, loud.
(laughs) I said it out loud.
- Oh, you did.
- I was like, "I just farted."
- "I just farted," to the audience.
(laughs)
She is so proud of that.
(upbeat music)
- That was fast.
(laughs)
(groans)
(imitating crying)
- Oh, that was a good answer.
Which is true, both people.
- Both of you.
(upbeat music)
- I think I wrote what she
wrote, just more efficiently.
Well, no, it could be totally different.
- Yes!
- Yes, oh, my God!
- I wrote, "group prayer."
- Prayer and I said,
"Hold hands in a circle
"and say a mantra three times with cast."
- Right, which is what Deborah
started from the pilot.
- From the pilot.
And for eight years,
every show.
- Every single show.
And it's good 'cause it bonds us.
(upbeat music)
- I've gotta learn how
to be more efficient.
(laughs)
All right, ready.
Coffee, oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
It's this just most brilliant scene
where he comes in holding a cup of coffee
and he does not stop talking,
he comes in and he's like (squeals).
And then, he kind of comes
back (laughs) into the van.
And he ends up going
and he closes the door.
- And they were so kind
because they knew how,
can I swear?
- [Crew Member] Yes.
They knew how fucking
hard I was concentrating.
I didn't stop talking
for like three pages.
So, all they saw on my face
was me just saying words.
But I liked it 'cause
it was a big challenge.
- It was fantastic.
(upbeat, guitar music)
- Oh, juggling.
- Oh, I was gonna put singing.
I thought you would put singing.
- Knitting and singing,
not at the same time.
Not at the same time.
- But you know what?
- [Sean] I remember you
used to always knit.
- I went through a crazy
knitting phase on set.
And it's very kind of you.
- And she would come in and be like,
"Look, I made this outfit,
look, I made this."
And I'm like, "What?
"That takes a company
like two years to make."
- (laughs) But it's
very kind of you to say
that it's a hidden talent of mine to sing.
(upbeat music)
There are so many.
- I spelled Matthew.
- [Crew Member] Wow.
- Because Matt and I
used to play softball.
- Do you realize how many episodes we had
and how many people came
on our show in eight years?
- Yes and we loved all of them.
- Oh, my God, I can't believe we got it!
- But the only thing is,
is Matt and I used to
play softball, right?
Like, on this little team in Santa Monica.
And I just asked him one day,
I'm like, "Hey, do you
want to do the show?"
And he was like, "Okay."
And that was it.
And so, we did the show.
I didn't think you were gonna say that
because he was more your storyline than--
Well, I guess he was both.
- No, he was the choir.
- [Sean] Yeah, he was
both but he dated you.
- He did, I tried to seduce him.
(upbeat music)
- We're not gonna get this one.
- Sugar, yes!
♫ That works
♫ Mine was more specific
- I know, I should've been.
(upbeat music)
I'm gonna preface this by
saying, I am colorblind.
(laughs)
- Either green or brown.
- What are they?
- They're hazel, they're green.
- Green.
- Yeah.
- I have no idea.
I literally honestly cannot
tell green, brown, red.
- But I've got orange around the center.
- Oh, she's a pumpkin,
she's got pumpkin eyes.
- I know that Sean was my brother.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- But through this game,
I learned that he really
is my best friend.
(laughs)
- I learned that because
she just said that,
I would probably sleep with her.
(gasps)
I also learned that
that's probably not true.
But also, I would say I learned nothing
because I already know
everything about her.
(gentle music)
- What do you mean you'd
sleep with me but not really?
- I don't know what I was saying.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)
(sign squeaks)